[Music]
hey what's up mkhd here and this
this is the sony xperia one mark ii
snapdragon 865 eight gigs of ram a 21x9
widescreen display triple cameras a 4
000 milliamp hour battery an all glass
and aluminum frame expandable storage
water resistance wireless charging
android 10
a high quality haptic motor fingerprint
reader and the power button a
revolutionary technology thin bezels no
hole punch or notch and just a clean
minimal modern form factor flagship
stuff right and that's fine but you know
technically anybody can build that
but the thing is this phone also has a
bunch of other stuff unique really
useful stuff that i haven't seen in any
other phone but all this stuff leads to
one question which is
why don't more people buy these like
sony's had a roughly zero percent market
share in smartphones for the past couple
of years in a row
and i think i have an answer
but first let me show you what is
actually so good about these so the
biggest one for me is this display so
i've mentioned this is a 21x9 aspect
ratio which we've seen a bit more now
you know it keeps it a bit narrower and
more comfortable on the hand more
reachable and i mentioned the thin
bezels they're not concerned with going
all the way to the edges and ending up
with a notch or a hole punch or
something and actually lets them keep
the front facing speakers so that's
awesome but this screen is also
4k
so it is a six and a half inch 4k screen
in your pocket which is crazy i remember
the first 4k phone i ever reviewed which
was back in college was also a sony
phone but yeah now even in 2020 there's
something wild about seeing that 2160p
option on a youtube video and toggling
it and legit looking about as good as
any other smartphone screen i've seen
also pro tip definitely go into display
settings and switch to creator mode if
you have this phone
which will give you the most accurate
color the best looking videos and photos
and yeah everything just looks really
good now here's something else it may
seem minor but this phone has a
tool-less micro sd card and sim card
tray just comes out just like that
now expandable storage is already
awesome but to go the extra mile on a
phone where people may also take a lot
of photos and videos and to engineer
this lever where you can pull the tray
out quickly and swap cards whenever you
want all while maintaining water
resistance is actually super impressive
this phone also keeps that headphone
jack so they didn't have to do that and
we all know they didn't have to do that
because sony clearly already sells some
of the best wireless earbuds and
wireless headphones on the market but
they kept that headphone jack anyway
good guy sony actually speaking of
headphones if you do order this phone
there's a bunch of bundles floating
around while they will bundle in their
world-class 350 dollar mark iv
headphones
for free
for free this phone has a lot of really
nice software features too like i said
it's got android 10 with sony's overlay
which is actually pretty close to stock
which may surprise a lot of people it's
a clean launcher with the google
explorer page next to the side quick
google search box at the bottom not a
whole lot of pre-installed apps either
but some nice added stuff here the
always-on display when it's enabled
we'll show you the icons for your most
recent apps to give you notifications
and they'll actually pulse to let you
know which one is your most recent
notification why it's buzzing there's
also easy multitasking on this tall
display and it is smooth and works
really well so check this out when you
hit the button in the middle it brings
you to a multitasker for both panels
where you can switch to a different app
or you can launch different app groups
so two at a time or quit out of it
entirely it is really well thought out
one of the best multitasking uis i've
used on android and i'll actually want
to use this phone also has a pretty
unique feature with the speakers i've
talked about where it will vibrate the
chassis
uh to act as extra bass
so it's kind of cheesy but it also is
kind of cool you turn it up and it
literally adds bass from the vibration
motor for those lower frequencies so in
songs with a bass line the phone is
literally buzzing in your hand with
every bass kick it's kind of wild you
might want to turn it on or off
depending on what you're doing but
that's also not something i've really
seen done on any other phone before and
this phone also even has an led
notification light up top which is rare
these days and an extra customizable
button at the bottom that can be used to
launch apps or use as a shutter button
for the camera and then speaking of the
cameras this is another area where you'd
expect maybe people would want to flock
to a phone like this because think about
it for as good as the best smartphone
cameras are the pixel cameras the
samsung cameras of the world
sony
makes all of the sensors for all of
those cameras and then on top of that
sony also happens to make their alpha
line of cameras their mirrorless stuff
including the a7 iii which has been
pretty much universally praised as a
technical masterpiece and potentially
just straight-up best camera of the year
for 2020. so sony sony's got camera tech
and sure enough what do you see sony is
in fact bringing a lot of the tech from
their alpha camera line down into these
cameras on the phone mainly the
incredible auto focus and that's what i
like the most but also a lot of manual
control so first of all if you just take
photos and videos in the automatic mode
in the standard app like most people
will you'll get a lot of good stuff
there's three 12 megapixel cameras the
primary the telephoto and then a truly
wide ultra wide which is awesome and
photos are pretty good very neutral you
know very very good dynamic range colors
are good sharpness is okay and focus is
fast but then there's also the included
pro level photo and video apps called
photo pro and cinema pro photo pro
basically shrinks the viewfinder and
gives you full on camera modes and
manual levels of control just like a
sony alpha camera it's actually so much
control that it requires a bit of a
learning curve to get used to shooting
it on an entirely touch screen interface
but there's a lot of stuff here it's
pretty awesome and it gives you
world-class auto focus object and eye
tracking your histograms your exposure
compensation metering modes all of that
and then the cinema pro app is even
crazier to me you get wide dynamic range
4k video with profiles with adjustable
manual controls iso control venice color
science
manual focus and even focus racking so
you can set two different focus points a
and b
and then have the camera smoothly rack
between them without hunting because
yeah you're you're totally making a
movie on your phone with this thing this
is next level dedication to enthusiasts
but i think
that actually kind of partially answers
the question we're considering in the
first place which is
why don't more people buy these why
don't more people buy and flock to these
awesome phones with tons of enthusiast
level features and part of the answer is
because
enthusiasts
really only make up a very very small
percentage of the overall market of
anything but especially of smartphones
now don't get me wrong enthusiasts
features do sell things sometimes but if
you want that true
high level volume of sales you need to
appeal to
everybody
and these kind of don't like for all
those awesome camera features i just
talked about and manual controls and
venice color science this phone also
just straight up doesn't have a simple
night mode like people want to just
quickly take a great low light photo
like pixel's night sight this doesn't
have that
the front facing camera is only 1080p
30. and we all know a growing mass of
people care about the front-facing
camera just as much if not more than the
back ones it's also a 4k 60hz display
and i bet you could hand this phone to a
thousand people and not tell them it has
a 4k display and ask them what they
think and you'd probably never get a
single person asking if it's a 4k screen
and also most people who already know
how to use and take the most advantage
of and really like this super high end
manual control on the cameras
most of those people already own and use
their own main mirrorless camera or
something like that
so don't get me wrong this is good for
those people it's an added feature but
this isn't a feature that's going to
sell new people take a look at this
chart
this is sony's volume of smartphone
sales for the past few years now
obviously this is a concerning trend
falling from nearly 40 million
smartphones a year for two years in a
row all the way down to just six and a
half million sold in 2018 for
perspective that's about as many iphones
as apple sells in a week in a strong
fourth quarter
so to get back in the game sony needs a
strong 2019 right they need to pull out
a few more smartphones get a little bit
more variety in there start appealing to
more people really good phones like the
xperia one mark ii and that should put
them back on the map for
oh
oh
that is not good at all and that's
because there's one more reason that
people don't buy these even though
they're clearly pretty cool and they're
pretty good and maybe they should
and that's because
they don't know about these and if you
think about it that's kind of crazy that
the company that makes all these popular
mirrorless cameras and this technical
masterpiece oh and also the playstation
and all these tvs and everything
that that company can't leverage
anything to get over zero percent in
smartphone market share and from my
perspective as a reviewer it's
frustrating because it seems like sony's
kind of suffering from some of the same
stuff lg has lately anyway which is
their inability to properly launch a
phone to the masses like take apple for
example we talk about them a lot but
they're notoriously very good at
launching a phone they'll have an event
then a week later you can pre-order and
then a week later they're in the streets
it doesn't take very long the hype
doesn't die
you know oneplus does this too samsung
does this too the good launches go that
way
this phone was unveiled
in may
may
so that's six months ago when it first
started showing up and i just got it
last week so may june july august
september october
that's a long time for the hype to die
and for a very poorly thought out launch
strategy and you know whether it is
poorly thought out or poorly executed it
just doesn't look good period and it
doesn't look like a priority for your
company when it takes that long matter
of fact it's taken so long for this
phone to come out that it's basically
successor has already launched it's
already been announced it's called the
xperia 5
mark ii
for some reason
sony's terrible with names and we won't
even get into that but you know that's a
slightly smaller version of this with
120 hertz display and a little bit of a
lower price
and when i go to b h to try to get my
hands on that
well it's not available till december so
of course people don't want to deal with
that especially when you're dealing with
expensive phones you don't want to have
your phone
arrive the day the sequel is announced
and that that's actually bad for
reviewers too reviewers want to know
that when they review a phone they have
all the most updated information and if
you didn't get one in may or june when
they were first getting seeded like i
didn't and you get one now
and the xperia 5 mark ii just came out
why would i even want to review this
phone anyway people aren't even going to
buy it so that's the frustrating thing
that's it's crazy that sony can make
such a great such an interesting
compelling little phone
and there'd just be absolutely no desire
to share it or buy it or anything but
here's the thing
here's the thing
i'm still rooting for sony because
i don't want to see this kind of stuff
die let's not forget the more
competition in any field the better the
products get and so while that downward
curve sort of makes it look like sony's
mobile division is on life support and
we've seen what that looks like in
others before
i don't want it to die
for both of us
either way that's been it let me know
what you think in the comments below
thanks for watching
and i'll catch you guys in the next one
peace